hello there guys and welcome to another
video in this video we have some huge
news regarding spider-man and also an
official tease for toby mcguire and
andrew garfield spider-man from the cast
of no way home so stay tuned for that
i'll get into that at the end of the
video so amy pascal the producer for no
way home has confirmed more spider-man
films are coming away in fact not one
but three new spider-man films a whole
nother trilogy with tom hall and
spider-man so the quote says this is not
the last movie that we're going to make
with marvel this is not the last
spider-man movie we're getting ready to
make the next spider-man movie with tom
holland and marvel we're thinking of
this as three films and we're going on
to the next three this is not the last
of the mcu movies so this is really
exciting news guys we in fact's getting
a whole nother trilogy of spider-man
films in the mcu now this makes me
wonder what are these films going to
focus on we can only speculate because
we won't know the answer until we watch
no way home but um i have a little bit
of a prediction and i think um at least
the fourth spider-man film will probably
see venom and perhaps a showdown between
spider-man and venom or maybe random's
new host will become peter peer-to-peer
and then something will happen there now
let's get into the other news that you
guys are probably waiting for the toby
maguire and andrew garfield tease so
firstly let me just play the clip let me
bring in two very special friends to
help out it makes sense for us to join
this announcement of course i mean who
else would it be when they say who else
will it be obviously they're referring
to toby maguire and andrew garfield so
marvel know what they're doing they're
continuing to tease us until the film's
release um i don't think we'll see them
in any upcoming promos or anything i
feel like they're going to just leave
them as a surprise for the film anyway
that's about it for this video a little
bit of a shorter one today but some
really big news with new spider-man
films coming out and an official tease
photo of a spider-man so let me know
what you guys think of this new news in
the comment section below and what would
you like to see from these new
spider-man films thanks for watching
guys i'll catch you in the next video